>> Sean: TUCKER CARLSON, SLOW
NEWS NIGHT, ANYTHING HAPPENING?
IT IS CERTAINLY SLOW, GREAT TO
SEE YOU, TUCKER GREAT SHOW.
BUCKLE UP WELCOME TO
>> Hannity: .
LET ME GIVE YOU A QUICK
HEADLINES IN THE DETAILS WE WILL
FOLLOW THAT NOBODY ELSE WILL
REPORT.
THE MUELLER WITCH HUNT IS
COMPLETELY OVER.
IT IS DONE.
NOBODY LISTENS TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND YEAH, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ADMITTED TODAY,
EVERYTHING WE RECORDED THE LAST
TWO YEARS, FULL CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS ARE NOW JUST
BEGINNING.
IMAGINE THAT, A TALK SHOW HOST
IS RIGHT AND SO MANY IN THE FAKE
NEWS INDUSTRY ARE WRONG.
WE WILL GET TO ALL OF IT BUT
FIRST BREAKING MOMENTS AGO, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR WILL NOT
HEAD BACK TO CAPITOL HILL TO BE
GRILLED BY JERRY NADLER'S
LAWYERS BECAUSE HE'S TOO WEAK TO
QUESTION HIM HIMSELF.
TONIGHT COME OF COURSE,
PREDICTABLY, MORE BREATHLESS
HYSTERIA, SELECTIVE MORAL
OUTRAGE FROM THE LEFT.
THEY ARE DESPERATELY TRYING TO
REVIVE WHAT IS NOW A DEAD, FAKE,
PHONY NARRATIVE.
THAT IS FINISHED.
THEY ARE WRONG.
THEY WERE WRONG.
THEY LIED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THEY CONTINUE TO LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY PERPETRATED A HOAX.
THEY PUSHED CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THEY LOST IN OPERATION
CROSS FIRE HURRICANE HAS NOW
TURNED INTO OPERATION BOOMERANG.
WE WILL HAVE FULL COVERAGE OF
HOW BARR, HOROWITZ, TWO AND THE
CORRUPT ACTORS IN THE DEEP STATE
THOSE THAT ABUSED POWER.
THEY WILL BRING EQUAL JUSTICE
AND EQUAL APPLICATION OF THE
LAWS TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT SEEMS, TONIGHT, FINALLY THE
CONSTITUTION AND RULE OF LAW
WILL BE FOLLOWED.
ALSO TONIGHT COME A MAJOR
BREAKING NEWS REPORT, BRAND-NEW
FROM JOHN SOLOMON SURROUNDING
BRUCE AND NELLIE WILL THEY BE IN
SERIOUS LEGAL TROUBLE?
I THINK WE PREDICTED THAT TOO
BUT THE MUELLER WITCH HUNT IS
OVER.
DON'T LET NOBODY ELSE FOR YOU.
THEY CAN TALK ABOUT IT TILL THE
COWS COME HOME.
THEY CAN SIT, GO HOME AND THEIR
HEADS CAN SPIN AROUND LIKE LINDA
BLAIR IN THE EXORCIST.
THEY CAN PROJECT VOMIT, THE
GREEN STUFF, AND IT WILL NOT
CHANGE THE TRUTH.
THE SECOND PART IS, WHAT WE HAVE
DILIGENTLY REPORTED, NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT FOR TWO YEARS
ON THIS PROGRAM, OUR ENSEMBLE
CAST COME I CAN'T NAME
EVERYBODY.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF US, BUT
TALK RADIO, RUSH LIMBAUGH, MARK
LEVAN AND A FEW OTHERS ON THE
CHANNEL.
LIKE LAURA, TUCKER, FOX &
FRIENDS, WE HAVE ALL BEEN RIGHT.
SO MANY OTHERS HAVE GOTTEN IT
DEAD WRONG.
THEY MISSED THE BIGGEST STORY IN
THEIR LIFETIME, AND WE CAN
CONFIRM TONIGHT THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS ARE, IN FACT,
UNDERWAY AND I MADE SURE THEY.
THAT IS THE BIGGEST HEADLINE TO
COME OUT OF TODAY AND I PROMISE
YOU KNOW ONE ELSE WILL REPORT
IT.
BUT NOT ACCORDING TO THE
DEMOCRATIC AND MEDIA MOB, THE
ONES THAT ARE FULL OF RAGE AND
PSYCHOTIC HATRED THAT, YOU KNOW
BORDERS ALL THINGS TRUMP.
THEY ARE OBSESSING ABOUT BARR'S
CONTENTIOUS HEARING ON
CAPITOL HILL WHICH COULD HAVE
BASICALLY BEEN WRAPPED UP
2 MINUTES.
AFTER THESE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS,
THIS IS THE MONEY MOMENT, IF YOU
WILL, LINDSEY GRAHAM, IT SAYS IT
ALL.
IT CONFIRMS WHAT I JUST TOLD
YOU.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO YOU SHARE MY CONCERNS
ABOUT THE FISA WARRANT PROCESS?
>> YES.
>> DO YOU SHARE THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AND WHY IT WAS
OPEN?
>> YES.
>> DO YOU SHARE MY CONCERNS THE
PROFESSIONAL FROM A LACK OF
PROFESSIONALISM, THE CLINTON
EMAIL INVESTIGATION, SOMETHING
WE SHOULD LOOK AT?
>> YES.
>> DO YOU EXPECT TO CHANGE YOUR
MIND ABOUT THE BOTTOM-LINE
CONCLUSIONS OF THE MUELLER
REPORT?
>> NO.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT'S CAMPAIGN IN 2017 WAS
THOROUGHLY LOOKED AT IN TERMS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THEY COLLUDED
WITH THE RUSSIANS?
>> YES.
AND THE ANSWER IS NO ACCORDING
TO BOB MUELLER.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
HE COULD NOT FIGHT ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION BUT YOU DID COME IS
THAT CORRECT?
>> YET THAT IS RIGHT.
>> DO YOU FEEL GOOD ABOUT YOUR
DECISION?
>> YES.
>> Sean: NO COLLUSION, NO
OBSTRUCTION AND AS WE SAID THE
BIGGEST HEADLINE NO ONE IN THE
MEDIA MOB WILL EVER TELL YOU HOW
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS
CONFIRMED TODAY, HE IS
INVESTIGATING FISA ABUSE, LICIT
SPINE, CLINTON'S RIGGED
INVESTIGATION, CLINTON'S
COLLUSION WITH HER DIRTY
DOSSIER, THE DIRTY DOSSIER.
UKRAINIAN COLLUSION AND SO MUCH
MORE.
REMEMBER, THAT IS ONLY BEGINNING
TODAY.
THERE IS SO MUCH, A CASCADE, AN
AVALANCHE OF INFORMATION.
WE WILL GET TO LINDSEY GRAHAM
WHO WILL JOIN US IN A MOMENT BUT
NEARLY 24 HOURS THE PREDICTABLE
MEDIA MOB IS TOTALLY, COMPLETELY
ABOUT A NEW REPORT FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
"NEW YORK TIMES."
LAST NIGHT, HOURS PRIOR TO
BARR'S HEARING, THE TWO FAR LEFT
MEDIA PROPAGANDA OUTLETS LIGHT
AGAIN CONVENIENTLY GRANTED
ACCESS TO A LEAKED LETTER FROM
TEAM MUELLER TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE THAT
EXPRESSED FRUSTRATION OVER HOW
BARR INITIALLY SUMMARIZED THE
REPORT.
"WASHINGTON POST" HEADLINE,
MUELLER COMPLAINED THAT BARR'S
LETTER DID NOT CAPTURE THE
ENTIRETY OF THE TRUMP ROAD.
BUT WITHIN THEIR OWN REPORTING
COME AWAY UNDERNEATH THE
HEADLINES, THEY ACTUALLY
CONTRADICTED THEIR OWN
HEADLINES.
THE ACTUAL TRUTH EMERGED.
ACCORDING TO A DOJ SPOKESPERSON,
NOW CONFIRMED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HIMSELF, THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL EMPHASIZED
NOTHING.
ZERO!
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S FOUR-PAGE
MARCH 24TH LETTER WAS INACCURATE
OR MISLEADING.
NOTHING!
BUT THAT EXPRESSED FRUSTRATION
OVER THE LACK OF CONTENT, AND
THE RESULTING MEDIA COVERAGE
REGARDING THE ANALYSIS.
HE IS CRITICIZED IN THE MEDIA
TOO.
SOMETHING MUELLER AND I HAVE IN
COMMON.
THIS IS HOW ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR RESPONDED EARLIER TODAY.
LET'S GO TO THE VIDEOTAPE.
>> I SAID, BOB, WHAT IS WITH THE
LETTER, YOU KNOW, WHY DON'T YOU
JUST PICK UP THE PHONE AND CALL
ME IF THERE IS AN ISSUE?
AND HE SAID THAT THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE WAY THAT THE
MEDIA WAS PLAYING THIS.
AND FELT THAT IT WAS IMPORTANT
TO GET OUT THE SUMMARIES, WHICH
THEY FELT, WOULD PUT THEIR WORK
IN PROPER CONTEXT.
AND AVOID SOME
OF THE CONFUSION THAT WAS
EMERGING.
AND I ASKED HIM IF HE FELT THAT
MY LETTER WAS MISLEADING OR
INACCURATE.
AND HE SAID, NO.
>> Sean: OH, SO ACCORDING TO
MUELLER COMMITTEE IS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S JOB TO SHAPE
HOW THE MEDIA REPORTS A STORY?
REALLY?
BOB?
BARR FOLLOWED UP WITH A SHOT AT
MUELLER'S BAND OF DEMOCRATIC
DONORS, HE APPOINTED.
EVEN THE GUY HILLARY'S VICTORY
PARTY, AN ATROCIOUS TRACK RECORD
AND OF COURSE THAT INCLUDED THE
HILLARY CLINTON ATTORNEY AS IT
RELATES TO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE LETTER IS A BIT SNOOTY
AND I THINK IT WAS WRITTEN BY
ONE OF THE SNAP -- STAFF PEOPLE.
DID YOU MAKE A WRITTEN
MEMORANDUM OF YOUR CONVERSATION?
DID YOU MAKE A MEMORANDUM OR
ANYONE ELSE?
DID ANYONE COME EITHER YOU OR
ANYONE ON YOUR STAFF,
MEMORIALIZE YOUR CONVERSATION
WITH ROBERT MUELLER?
>> YES.
>> WHO DID THAT?
>> THERE WERE NOTES TAKEN.
>> MAY WE HAVE THOSE NOTES?
>> NO.
>> Sean: NO.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU HAVE GOT TO LOVE THAT.
LET'S TAKE A MOMENT TO LAY OUT
THE FACTS ONE MORE TIME.
WELL, SOME PEOPLE JUST NEED TO
KNOW WHERE THIS IS GOING.
WE ARE TRYING TO EDUCATE THEM.
AND IT IS HARD.
THEY ARE SO ENTRENCHED IN THEIR
OWN CONSPIRACY THEORIES, LIES IN
THEIR OWN MIND COME I ACTUALLY
BELIEVE THAT THEY BELIEVE THEIR
LIES AT THIS POINT.
ZERO EVIDENCE THAT ANYONE IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH
RUSSIA.
MUELLER DID NOT MAKE A
DETERMINATION ON OBSTRUCTION.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL INDICATED
THESE BASIC FINDINGS IN HIS
LETTER MARCH 24TH.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THEN
DETERMINED, YES, NO OBSTRUCTION
TOOK PLACE AND APRIL 18TH,
MUELLER RELEASED THE FULL REPORT
WITH ONLY A FEW MANDATED
REDUCTIONS BECAUSE OF A WELL
SUPPORTED BY DEMOCRATS FOLLOWING
THE START INVESTIGATION INTO
BILL CLINTON.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAD NO
OBLIGATION WHATSOEVER TO RELEASE
ANY OF THE MUELLER REPORT.
THAT IS THE TRUTH.
THAT IS THE LAW.
THESE ARE THE FACTS.
AND SENATOR TED CRUZ POINTED OUT
EARLIER TODAY THE COMPLAINTS TO
THE LEFT ARE TOTALLY ABSURD.
TAKE A LOOK.
SO THEIR ENTIRE ARGUMENT IS,
GENERAL BARR, YOU SUPPRESSED
THE 19 PAGES THAT ARE ENTIRELY
PUBLIC, THAT WE HAVE, THAT WE
CAN READ, THAT THEY KNOW EVERY
WORD OF IT.
AND THEY ARE COMPLAINT IS IT WAS
DELAYED A FEW WEEKS.
AND THAT WAS BECAUSE OF YOUR
DECISION NOT TO RELEASE THE
REPORT PIECE MAIL BUT THE 19
PAGES ALONG WITH THE ENTIRE 448
PAGES PRODUCED BY THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
>> YES.
>> IF THAT IS THEIR ARGUMENT, I
HAVE TO SAY THAT IS AN
EXCEPTIONALLY WEAK ARGUMENT.
BECAUSE IF YOU ARE HIDING
SOMETHING, I WILL TELL YOU RIGHT
NOW GENERAL BARR, YOU ARE DOING
A LOUSY JOB OF HIDING IT.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, THE MEDIA
MOB, DEMOCRATIC MOB, THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT FACTS.
TRULY AN AGENDA AND BY THE BY
NOT SERVING WE THE PEOPLE, WHICH
IS WHY THEY ARE SMEARING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND EVEN
CALLING FOR HIM TO BE IMPEACHED.
IT WON'T GO ANYWHERE, BUT TAKE A
LOOK ANYWAY.
>> THE TOP LAW-ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL IN THE LIMITED DID HE
MISLEAD THE CONGRESS AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO PROTECT THE
PRESIDENT?
>> HE WAS BEING DECEPTIVE AND HE
KNEW HE WAS.
>> THERE WAS AN EASE IN WHICH
BARR LIED.
THERE ARE A CONTRADICTION --
CONTRADICTIONS AND A MYSTIFYING
PERFORMANCE.
>> I THINK IT IS IN PATTERNS.
THEY ATTORNEY GENERAL SAYS
TUESDAY IS MONDAY AND THE SUN IS
THE MOON.
FILLED WITH LIES AND
MISREPRESENTATION AND NOW I
THINK THERE ARE CASES WE CAN
POINT TO YOU THAT PEOPLE WILL
SAY OR PERJURY.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO HAS
PRESENTED HIMSELF IN A WAY THAT
IS NOT REPEATABLE ANYMORE.
HE HAS FULLY, OBVIOUSLY,
CORRUPTED.
>> Sean: ONCE AGAIN THE MEDIA
MERELY DOING THE VIDEO.
THE ALLIES AND RADICAL SOCIALIST
PARTY MORE INTERESTED IN
GRANDSTANDING AND RAGE HATING
TRUMP AND LEGISLATING ON BEHALF
OF YOU, WE THE PEOPLE, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> I THINK IT IS HARSH.
I THINK YOUR CREDIBILITY IS
UNDERMINED WITHIN THE DEPARTMEN
DEPARTMENT.
IN THIS COMMITTEE, AND WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> MR. BARR, YOU SEEM TO HAVE
KNOWN THE FILIBUSTER RULES
BETTER THAN THE SENATORS DO.
>> YOUR ANSWER WAS PURPOSELY
MISLEADING, AND I THINK OTHERS
DO TOO.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THAT
YOU ARE NO DIFFERENT THAN RUDY
GIULIANI OR KELLYANNE CONWAY OR
THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO SACRIFICE
THEIR ONCE DECENT REPUTATION FOR
THEIR ONCE DECENT REPUTATION FOT
THEIR ONCE DECENT REPUTATION FOE
THEIR ONCE DECENT REPUTATION FOD
THEIR ONCE DECENT REPUTATION FOI
THEIR ONCE DECENT REPUTATION FOT
THEIR ONCE DECENT REPUTATION FOR
THEIR ONCE DECENT REPUTATION FOA
THEIR ONCE DECENT REPUTATION FOD
LIAR IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
HAVE CHOSEN TO BE THE
PRESIDENT'S LAWYER AND SIGHED
WITH HIM OVER THE INTEREST OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sean: BELIEVE IT OR NOT THE
FAKE NEWS "NEW YORK TIMES"
OPINION PAGE MELODRAMATIC WHERE
JAMES COMEY, WELL, THEATRICALLY
EXCLAIMING "MR. TRUMP, EAT YOUR
SOUL."
IN SMALL BITES COME I CAN'T SAY
IT WITH A STRAIGHT FACE.
THE DISGRACED FBI DIRECTOR WHO
SAID "YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO
REMAIN SILENT.
I SUGGEST YOU USE IT.
YOU WILL PROBABLY REGRET NOT
LISTENING TO ME."
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S SOLOIST
BECAUSE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PERHAPS IT IS TIME FOR MR. COMEY
TO FINALLY WIPE AWAY HIS TEARS
FROM GETTING CANNED AND REALIZE
THAT JIM, THE WRITING IS ON THE
WALL.
TRUST ME.
YOU ARE IN SERIOUS TROUBLE
TONIGHT, LEGAL JEOPARDY.
YOU ABUSED YOUR POWER.
I KNOW YOU ARE THINKING YOU ARE
SUPER PATRIOT BUT A LOT OF THE
FBI I KNOW ARE EMBARRASSED BY
WHAT YOU DID IT.
IT WAS THE FIRST FBI OFFICIAL TO
SIGN OFF ON THAT FISA LAURENT
DESPITE THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE CARTER PAGE, OH, BASED
ON UNVERIFIED, AND COOPERATED,
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN OFF TO RESEARCH AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS TELLING
US MAY HAVE BEEN RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
YOU SIGNED UP ON THAT.
HE IS THE ONE THAT TOLD
PRESIDENT-ELECT MONTHS LATER
IT'S A DOSSIER WAS UNVERIFIED.
NOT WHAT HE SAID IN THE FISA
WARRANT.
HE SAID IT WAS SALACIOUS MONTHS
AFTER USE THE FISA WARRANT.
DID HE LIE IN OCTOBER,
JANUARY 2017, OCTOBER 2016?
HE MET WITH SUSAN RICE,
PRESIDENT OBAMA, CRAZY UNCLE JOE
WITH THE DOSSIER OF THE
ELECTION.
HE LICKED GOVERNMENT MEMOS --
MEMOS WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
ORDER TO SPUR SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION AND THAT MIGHT BEA
CRIME EVEN THOUGH HE WAS THE ONE
THAT DECLARE THE PRESIDENT
AND FBI DIRECTOR FOR ANY OR NO
REASON AT ALL.
HE HAS THE ONE SURROUNDED
HIMSELF WITH PARTISAN CORRUPT
HIGH-RANKING OFFICIALS WHO HAVE
ALL EITHER RESIGNED, BEEN FIRED
OR DEMOTED.
AND HOW JAMES COMEY IS THE ONE
ALONG WITH FELLOW DEEP STATE
COUNTERPARTS THE TABLES HAVE NOW
TURNED.
A NEW SHERIFF IN TOWN.
HIS NAME IS BILL BARR.
AND HE CONFIRMED TODAY THE
INVESTIGATION INTO YOUR ACTIONS.
THE DEEP STATE SPYING AND ALL
THE OTHER SHENANIGANS THAT
HAPPEN, WRECKING HILLARY'S
INVESTIGATION, TRYING TO
BLUDGEON THE PRESIDENT DULY
ELECTED BY WEEK, THE PEOPLE OF
THE UNITED STATES.
WE NOW KNOW NOW KNOW HOROWITZ
INVESTIGATION INTO FISA ABUSE,
INVESTIGATION INTO LEAKING COME
UP, UP MORE INTO CHRISTOPHER
STEELE'S LAW AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY ANDD
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY ANDM
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY ANDC
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY ANDA
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY ANDI
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY ANDC
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY ANDL
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY ANDU
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY ANDI
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY ANDN
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY ANDW
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY ANDT
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY ANDH
UKRAINE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GIVE US THE
EVIDENCE.
A MASKING REQUEST CARRIED OUT BY
SUSAN RICE, SAMANTHA POWER IN
2016, 350% INCREASED CRIMINAL
REFERRALS ARE COMING IN HERE.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
SUPPOSED TO BE DEMOCRATIC
REPUBLIC BASED ON THE RULE OF
LAW, A CONSTITUTION.
IT IS NOT A BUREAUCRATIC
DICTATORSHIP WHERE POWER IS
ABUSED AND USED BY A SELECT FEW
UNELECTED, UNACCOUNTABLE
OFFICIALS.
WE GIVE YOU THESE TOOLS BECAUSE
WE TRUST YOU TO PROTECT THIS
COUNTRY.
NOT USE THEM AND TURN THEM ON
THE ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOW TIME WE EITHER GET
THIS STRAIGHT OR SAY GOODBYE,
USA.
BECAUSE AS ATTORNEY GENERAL,
BARR POINTED OUT, OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM MUST NEVER BE
USED, EVER USED AS A POLITICAL
WEAPON, EVER AGAIN!
RIGHT, JIM?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE REPORT IS NOW IN THE
HANDS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
EVERYONE CAN DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES.
THERE IS AN ELECTION IN 18
MONTHS.
THAT IS VERY DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
BUT WE ARE OUT OF IT.
WE HAVE TO STOP USING THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PROCESS AS A
POLITICAL WEAPON.
TO THE EXTENT THERE WAS OVER
REACHED MY DON'T WANT TO JUDGE
PEOPLE'S MOTIVES AND COME TO
CONCLUSION ON THAT.
BUT TO THE EXTENT THERE WAS
OVERREACH, WHAT WE HAVE TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT IS, YOU KNOW, A
FEW PEOPLE AT THE TOP GETTING
INTO THEIR HEADS THAT THEY KNOW
BETTER THAN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> I HAVE SET UP BEFORE AND I
WILL SAY IT AGAIN, JIM COMEY,
SUPER PATRIOT, YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO REMAIN SILENT AND I
SUGGEST YOU KIND OF LISTEN.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD STOP WRITING
ALL BEDS AND START LOOKING IN